The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at OCW.MIT.edu.
JAMES DICARLO: I'm
going to shift more
towards this decoding
space than we talked about,
the linkage between neural
activity and behavioral report.
And I introduced that a bit.
You just saw that there's some
population powerful activity
in IT.
And I'm going to expand
on that a bit here.
But sort of stepping back,
when you think about it again,
what I call an end
to end understanding,
going from the image all
the way to neural activity
to the perceptual report, one
of the things we want to do,
again, is just define
a decoding mechanism
that the brain uses to support
these perceptual reports.
Basically what neural
activity are directly
responsible for these tasks?
And I'll come back to
later this encoding side.
It's like, you know,
and notice I'm putting
these in this order, right?
So once you know what
the relevant aspects
of neural activity are in IT,
or wherever you think they are,
then that sets a target
for what is the image
to neural transformation that
you're trying to explain?
Not predict any neural
response, but those
particular aspects of
the neural response.
So that's what I mean by
the relevant ventral stream
patterns of activity.
So we start here.
We work to here, and then
we work to here, rather than
the other way around.
OK, so I'm going
to try it again.
Keep with the domain I set up.
I talked about core recognition.
I now need to start
to define tasks.
I'm going to talk about specific
tasks that are, for now, let's
call them basic level nouns.
I'm actually going to relax
that to subordinate tasks
in a minute.
But here they are.
Car, clock, cat.
These are not the actual nouns.
I'll show you the ones we use.
But just to fix
ideas, we're imagining
a space of all possible
nouns that you might use
to describe what you just saw.
And I'm going to have a
generative image domain.
So I now have a
space of images here.
I'm not just going to
draw these off the web.
We're going to
generate our own image
domain that we think
engages on the problem,
but gives us control of
the latent variables.
So I'll show you that now.
So the way we're
going to do this
is by generating one
foreground object in each image
that we're going to show.
And we just did this by
taking 3-D models like these--
this is a model of a car.
We can control it's other latent
variables beyond its identity.
So this is a car.
It has a particular car type.
So there's a couple of latent
variables about identity here
that relate to the geometry.
Then there's these position--
other latent variables like
position, size, and
pose that I mentioned,
that are unknowns that make
the problem challenging.
And we can then just,
like, render this thing.
And we could place it on any
old background we wanted to.
And what we did was we
tended to place them
on uncorrelated
naturalistic backgrounds.
And that creates these sort
of weirdish looking images.
Some of them may look
sort of natural, hence,
this looks pretty unnatural.
But the reason we did this.
Why would you do this?
So-- so we did this because we
could add a generative space.
And because it was-- so we know
what's going on with the latent
variables we care about.
And we also, when we built this,
it was challenging for computer
vision systems to
deal with this,
even though humans could
naturally-- you know,
they don't have advantage
of any contextual cues
here because by construction,
these are uncorrelated.
We just took natural
images and would randomly
put objects on them.
But this was enough to fool
a lot of the computer vision
systems at the time that tended
to rely on the contextual cues.
Like blue in the background
signals or being an airplane,
we didn't want those kind
of things being done.
We wanted the actual
extraction of object identity.
And again, humans
could do it quite well.
So that's why we
ended up in this sort
of maybe this no man's
land of image space, which
is not very simple, but not
ImageNet just pulled off
off the web.
And so that's how we got there.
And just to give you a
sense that this is actually
quite doable for humans,
I'll show you a few images.
I won't even cue
you what they are.
I'm going to show them
for 100 milliseconds.
You can kind of shout
out what object you see.
AUDIENCE: Car.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES DICARIO: Right.
So see, it's pretty
straightforward, right?
And those look weird, you
can do that quite well.
And you know, here's the kind of
images that we would generate.
This would be-- so when
we think of image bags,
we think of partitions
of image space.
This is some images that
would correspond to faces.
These are all images of faces
under some transformations.
Again, different backgrounds.
These are not faces.
These are other objects
again, under transformations.
And we can have as many
of these as we want.
We call this one--
this distinction, when
shown for 100 milliseconds--
is one core recognition test.
Discriminate face for not face.
Here is a subordinate task.
This is beetle from not beetle.
This is a particular
type of car.
You can see it's
more challenging.
Again, we don't show
these images like this.
This is just to
show you the set.
We show them one at a time.
And so let me now
go ahead and say,
we're going to try to make
a predictive model using
that kind of image space to
see if we can understand what
are the relevant aspects
of neural activity
that can predict human
report on an image space?
And when I say we, I
mean Naiib Maiai and Ha
Hong, who are post-doc
and graduate student
that were in the lab that
led this experimental work.
And Ethan Soloman and Dan Yamins
also contributed to the work.
So what we did was to try to
record a bunch of IT activity
to measure what's going
on in the population
as I showed you earlier, but
now in this more defined space
where we're going to collect
a bunch of human behavior
to compare possible
ways of reading IT
with the behavior of the human.
This is how we started.
We're now doing monkeys--
where we're recording and
the monkey's doing a task.
But what we did here was we
just passively fixating monkeys,
compared with behaving humans.
And as I showed you
earlier, monkeys and humans
have very similar
patterns of behavior.
So what we record
from IT, in this case,
we were using array
recording electrodes.
These are chronically implanted.
This shows them here.
You implant them
during a surgery,
as kind of is shown here.
Down in the IT cortex.
You can get their size here.
There are about hundred--
there's actually 96
electrodes on each of them.
They typically yield about
half of the electrodes
having active neurons on them.
So you get, you know, on the
order of 150 recording sites.
And you can lay them out.
You can lay-- we would
typically lay out
three of them across IT and
V4 to record a population
sample out of IT.
And we would do this across
among multiple monkeys.
And here's an example of the
kind of data we would get.
This is 168 IT recording sites.
This is similar to what
I showed you earlier.
This is the mean response
in a particular time window
out of IT, similar to
what I showed you earlier
in that study with Gabriel.
And what we do here is, I'm just
showing you to give you feel.
That's one image.
Here is eight more--
here's seven more images.
And these are just
the population vectors
in a graphic form.
And but we actually
collected nearly 25--
this is 2,560 images.
This is sort of
the mean response
data of this 168 neurons.
And now you have this again,
this rich population data.
And you can ask, what's
available in there
to support these tasks?
And how well does it predict
human patterns of performance
on those tasks?
So in this study, that's
all we were asking to do.
We're trying to do
more and more recently.
But let me show you what all
we were trying to do is to say,
look.
One thing we observed,
even though you
saw that car-- you could
do car, you could do faces.
It seemed like you
were doing 100%.
Turns out you're better at
some things than others.
So discriminate-- this is
a deep prime map of humans.
So red means good performance.
High D prime.
You know, a D prime of
3 is something like--
I don't know, psychophysicists
in the room may correct me.
A D prime of 3 is sort of
on the order of 90 some 95%
correct, in that range.
So these are very high
performance levels
when you get up to 5.
0 is chance.
So 50%-- well this
is an eight way task.
So one over 8% correct.
So the subjects were doing
either eight way basic level
tasks, or eight way subordinate
cars, or eight way faces.
And these are the D prime
levels under different amounts
of variation of those
other latent variables
position size and pose.
Don't worry about those details.
What I want you to
see is the color here.
So look, it's tables versus--
discriminating tables from
all these other objects.
You do that at a
very high D prime.
Discriminating beetles
from other cars,
you do it at slightly
lower D prime.
You can see this, specially
at a high variation,
you're actually starting to
get down to lower performance.
And faces-- one face
versus another face,
you're actually
quite poor at that.
You're a little bit
better than chance.
But it's actually quite
challenging in 100 milliseconds
without hair and
glasses to discriminate
those 3-D kind of face models.
I showed you Sam and
Joe earlier as examples.
You're actually quite
challenging to do
that for humans in
that domain of faces.
So, what I want to
show you here is
you have this pattern of
behavioral performance.
You have all this IT activity.
This is humans.
This is monkeys.
And what we wanted
to do is say, look.
We can use this pattern.
This is very repeatable
across humans.
Can we use this repeatable
behavioral pattern
to understand what
aspects of this activity
could map to that?
And again, this
pattern is reliable.
I just said that.
And it's not as if you
can predict this pattern
by just running classifiers
on pixels or V1.
In fact, I'll show
you that a minute.
But we thought there's
some aspects of IT activity
that would predict this.
And we wanted to try to
find those aspects to--
so, again, this was motivated
by that study I showed you
earlier.
So which part of the
IT population activity
could predict this behavior
over all recognition tasks?
We're seeking a general
decoding model that would work.
Here's some specific tasks.
But we'd like it to be--
work over any task that we
could imagine testing humans
within this domain
of taking 3D models,
putting them under variation.
Work over that entire domain.
That was what we
were hoping to do.
So again, I'll briefly
take you through this.
Because I already
showed you this earlier.
Again, we've previously shown
that you could kind of take
this kind of state
space, and say hey,
can you separate images
of faces from non-faces,
using these simple
linear classifiers, which
are essentially weighted
sums on the IT activity?
And now we wanted
to ask, could this
predict human behavioral
face performance,
and monkey, because again,
they're very similar.
And not only would
this class of decoding
models that was motivated by the
earlier work predict this task,
but would predict car detection?
Would the same model predict
car one versus car two?
That's a subordinate task.
And all such tasks.
Again, over the whole domain,
can you take a same decoding
strategy and take
the data and say,
I'm going to just learn on
a certain number of training
examples, build a
classifier, and then I'll
say that's my model
of how the human does
every one of these tasks.
And if that's true,
then it should perfectly
predict that pattern
or performance
that I just showed you earlier.
And so here was again, this
was the working hypothesis.
Passively evoked spike rates
using single fixed time
scale that are spatially
distributed, because they're
sampled over IT, over a single
fixed number of non-human--
of non-human primate cortex.
So a single number of neurons.
And learn from a reasonable
number of training examples.
So all of that is a decoding
class of models that we thought
might work.
And if this is correct--
this is what I just
said-- it should predict
the behavioral data that we
collect.
For example, the D prime
data I just showed you.
But also more fine grained
behavioral data in principle.
So I want to just
step back to make
it clear that it's not obvious
that this should work, right?
I mean, it depends--
in the audience, I get people
on completely different sides
of this, whether this
should work or not.
So, you know, one thing
is, like, well look,
it's passively evoked.
You heard Gabriel say, well,
you didn't like passive tasks.
And I agree with that.
In the ideal world,
the animal will
be actively doing the task.
And then you'd say, well I'll
measure while the animal's
doing the task.
That's going to be your
best chance of prediction.
But we also saw earlier
that that passively
evoked monkey still--
you know, nobody would argue
that a passively evoked
retinal data is not going to be
somewhat applicable to vision.
And you know, the
question is, how much
of those arousal effects
show up in a place
like IT cortex, which
is typically high?
Which is high up in
the ventral stream.
So you could argue
both sides of this.
But it's possible that
attentional arousal mechanisms
are needed to make this a good
predictive linkage between that
to sort of activate IT in this
sort of crude way, if you like.
Some people have pointed
out that you need the trial
by trial coordinated
spike timing
structure to actually
make good predictions,
that those are critical.
Some people have pointed out
that you have to kind of assign
different parts of IT to
particular roles, which is
a prior on the decoding space.
For instance, that you could
believe that biologically,
an animal's born.
There's some tissue that's
going to be dedicated to faces.
You have to wire those neurons
downstream to that tissue.
And that means you're going to
restrict the decoding space,
rather than just letting them
learn from the space of IT
as if they collected
samples off of all of IT.
So I think some
people implicitly
believe that even if it's
not stated quite that way.
IT does not directly
underlie recognition.
You could imagine that.
I mean, it's not for sure known.
And some lesions of IT
don't produce deficits
in recognition.
That's a possibility.
Maybe you need too
many training examples.
Monkey neural codes cannot
explain human behavior.
You know, again, but
I already showed you
monkeys and humans
are very similar.
So these are the
reasons that you
might say this is negative,
and might not work.
And probably
already have guessed
that I'm telling all these
negatives because it turns out
this simple thing works quite
well for the grain of behavior
that I've shown you so far.
And here's my evidence of that.
So this is actual behavioral
performance out of humans
that I showed you earlier.
This is mean D prime.
This is the predicted
behavior or performance
of taking a classifier, reading
from that IT population data
that I've shown you, which
gives a predicted D prime.
Here is-- we first
chose a decoder.
We had to match things
like the number of neurons.
We had to get it in
the ballpark, so--
because again, there's
a free variable,
as I showed you earlier.
There's at least one.
But for now, let's think of
matching the number of neurons
to get you near the
diagonal, so that you
have sufficient number
of neural recordings
to say, how well do you do
on a face detection task?
And then, here's
all the other tasks.
This is those 64 points
that I showed you earlier.
Here's some examples like
fruit versus other things, car
versus other things.
And you should see that all
these points kind of line up
along this diagonal, which
says, wow, this is actually
quite predictive, that I
can take this simple thing
and predict all the stuff
that we've collected so far.
And so let me now kind
of be more concrete
about what is the
inferred neural mechanism
that we're testing here?
Well, I'll show you in a minute.
This is, for each
new object, we think
what happens is some
downstream observer,
a downstream neuron, randomly
samples roughly 50,000
single neurons, spatially
distributed over all of IT,
not biased to any compartments.
Listens to each IT sites.
When I say listen
in this case, we
think could average
over 100 milliseconds.
We're not sure about this.
This is just the version
that's shown here.
Learn an appropriate weighted
sum of those IT spiking.
And then listen at 10%.
That's basically,
once you learn,
there's a heavily weighted
about 10% of the IT neurons
are heavily weighted
for each of the tasks.
That's just an observation
that we have in our data.
But this is trying to map it
to neuroscientist language
from these decoder
versions out of IT.
So what that is a
model that says,
learn weighted sums of 50,000
random average 100 milliseconds
single unit responses
distributed over all IT.
So a bunch of stuff in
here is what your model
is sort of encapsulating.
That's still too long.
So I made a little
acronym out of that.
And that caught Laws of
RAD IT decoding mechanism.
So this is just to say there's
a hypothesis of how everything
might work, but now can be make
predictions for other objects
and could potentially
be falsified.
So, so far, this model works
quite well over these tasks.
And in fact, the
correlation is 0.92.
You might look at this and
say, oh, it's not perfect.
But it turns out that
that's about the level
that which humans
differ from each other.
So it's passing a Turing test,
that this mechanism read off
of the monkey IT hides
in the distribution
of the human population that
we're asking to also perform
these same tasks.
So it can't be
distinguished from being
a human in these tasks.
You guys, watch "X Machina?"
Wasn't that a movie I saw?
Doesn't pass that test.
Passes just a simple
core recognition test.
But so that was a
Turing test of this.
So OK, so, this is
here that I quantified.
So this is human to
human consistency.
That's the range
I just mentioned
that, you've got to get
into here to pass our Turing
test on this.
And that's a decoding
mechanism I just showed you.
There's other ways of reading
out of IT that don't pass.
There's ways of reading out of
V4, which you recorded from--
none of them we've tried are
able to get you to this here.
That doesn't mean
V4 isn't involved.
V4 is the feeder to IT.
It just means you can't take
simple decodes off of V4
and naturally
produces this pattern.
And that's similar for like,
pixels or V1 representations.
So lower level representations
don't naturally
predict this
pattern of behavior.
And even some
computer vision codes
that we tested at the time, as
you can see, if those of you
know these older computer
vision models didn't do this.
But more recent computer
vision models actually do.
And I'll show you
that at the end.
OK.
So, this is a little
bit for the aficionados
to tell you how
we got there as we
increase the number of units in
IT, that drives performance up.
So as you read more and
more units out of IT,
you get better and
better performance.
That's also true out of V4.
But I'm trying to
show you this here,
is it's like, not the
absolute performance
that is the good thing
to compare a model
with actual behavioral data.
It's the pattern of
performance, which
we call the consistency
with the humans.
That's that correlation
along that diagonal
that I showed you
earlier, that tasks
that are hard for the models
are also hard for the humans.
Tasks that are easy for humans
are also easy for the models.
And you could
imagine doing that,
not just at the task level,
but at the image level as well.
And anyway, that's
what's quantified here.
And you see that when you get up
to around you know, about 100--
I showed you 168
recordings out of IT.
This point right there
is about 500 IT features.
And taking you
through some things
that maybe I won't
have time for,
that's actually how we
approximate that 50,000 single
IT neuron number.
That's an inference
from our data
based on if we didn't actually
record 50,000 single neurons.
But from these kind
of plots, we're
able to make a pretty good guess
that this kind of model right
here would produce--
would land right there.
To be consistent with
humans, and would
get the absolute
level of performance
which humans matched.
And you know, the models
we tried out of V4,
this is one example of them.
They can get performance.
But they can never-- they
don't match this pattern
of performance naturally.
They over perform on some tasks,
and under-perform on others.
They sort of reveal
themselves as not
being human like by being too
good at some things, right?
So that's a way to
fail the Turing test.
OK.
Maybe I'll skip through this,
it's sort of the same thing.
This is about training examples.
If those of you guys
care about this,
I could kind of take you through
how we-- there's actually
a family of solutions in there.
And I'm just telling you about
one of them for simplicity.
So, let me then just take
it down to another grain.
So that was the
pattern of performance,
it's actually
naturally predicted
by this first decoding
mechanism that we tried.
But what about the
confusion pattern?
So not just the absolute D
primes for each of these tasks,
but there's finer grained data,
like how often an animal is
confused with a fruit, or an
animal's confused with a face.
These are the confusion
pattern data here.
I'm sorry I don't have
the color bars up.
All I'm going to need you
to do is say, well these
are the confusion patterns
that we predicted.
And this is what is the
predicted confusion pattern,
if I gave the machine, the
IT, these ground truth labels.
And it predicts this.
This is what actually
happened in human data.
And what I want to sort of
look at this and this, and say,
there actually
look quite similar.
Their noise corrected
correlation is 0.91.
So they were still quite good at
predicting confusion patterns.
Although this did
not hold up fully.
We're only at 0.68.
I say only.
Some people would
say this is success.
We're only at 0.68
on high variation.
So there's a failure
here of the model.
That should be at 1, because
it's noise corrected.
So there's something
about this that's
not quite right at
predicting the confusion
patterns of humans at
high variation images.
And that to us, that's an
opening to push forward, right?
So this is a strategy
going forward
as we have an initial guess
of how you read out of IT.
It looks pretty good
for first grain test.
But now we can turn
the crank harder.
We need more neural data.
We need more psychophysics,
finer grained measurements
to sort of distinguish
among, not just
say IT's better than V4 or
those other representations.
But what exactly about
the IT representation?
Is it 100 milliseconds?
What time scale?
Maybe those synchronous
codes do matter.
Some of those things that
I put on there earlier
might start to matter when
we push the code-- push
this even further.
So what I take home
here is that you
do quite well with this
first order rate code
reads out of IT.
But now there's an opportunity
to try to dig in and say,
well at what point
do they break down?
And what kind of
decoding models are you
going to replace them with?
And that's what
we're trying to do.
I've told you that IT
does good at identity.
But remember I said
earlier on, remember
I showed you those
manifolds, and said
there's other latent variables
like position and scale.
And I said those
don't get thrown away.
They just get unwrapped, right?
Remember that manifold
picture I showed earlier?
And so one of the things
we've been doing recently
is asking, because we
built these images,
we know these other
latent variables,
like position and
pose-- that was
one of the advantages of
building the images this way.
And we've been asking how well
IT encodes those other latent
variables about the
pose of the object,
the position of the object.
And to make-- let me
just skip through.
To make a long story short,
IT actually encodes--
not only has information
about these kind of variables,
which is really not
surprising, because others
have shown that
there's information
about those kind
of things before.
But that's sort
of what's on here.
Everything what I'm
showing here, here's
IT V4 simulated V1 in pixels.
And always, everything goes
up along the ventral stream
for the other
variables, which may be
non-intuitive to some of you.
I mean, because position
is supposed to be V1.
But position of an object
in a complex background
is better at IT.
That's one example.
But all these latent
variables go up
along the ventral
stream in terms
of their ease of decoding.
But what I'm most
excited about is
that if you do this
comparison with humans again,
you actually get this sort
of, again, pretty decent,
not quite as tight correlation,
between the human--
actual measured
behavioral performance
on making estimates of those
other latent variables,
and the predicted behavioral
performance out of IT.
And again, much
better correlations.
It's not perfect.
So again, there's some gap here,
some failure of understanding.
But much better than if you
read out of V4, V1 or pixel.
So this says that the
representation again isn't just
an identity thing.
It seems like this could
be representational
underlie some of these
other judgments, at least
at the central 10 degrees for
sort of foreground objects
as we've been measuring here.
That's the-- don't worry about
the details on here-- that's
the upshot of what I'm trying
to say with this slide.
But I just wanted to
put that out there
so you didn't forget that
you haven't thrown away
all this other interesting
stuff about what's
out there in the scene.
OK.
Let me kind of--
I've sort of alluded
to this a bit.
I want to come back
to kind of now,
this is like Marr
level 3 stuff, right?
So you have this idea of
what you're trying to solve.
You have a decode--
you have an algorithm that's
a decoder on a basis, that's
trying-- that looks like
it predicts pretty well.
It's not perfect.
There's work to be done there.
But it actually does quite well.
Now what does that mean on
the physical hardware level?
So that's Marr level 3.
So you think-- here's
how I visualize it.
You have IT cortex,
which I mean AIT and CIT.
So it's about 150 square
millimeters in a monkey.
And remember I told you
there was about 1 millimeter
scale of organization?
I showed you that earlier.
And others have shown--
I showed this earlier,
too-- that there's
sort of face regions.
So I've drawn them just
for sort of for scale here,
just a schematic.
That they're slightly
bigger organizations,
they're 2 to 5 millimeter.
So I think of IT as being
this sort of like 100 to 200
little--
similar to Tanaka.
This is not a new
conceptual idea.
But there's sort of
just the simple version
would be each millimeter does
exactly the same thing, is
a feature.
And if you sample off of
that, you take 5,000 neurons,
but they're really sampling
from only about 150 IT
features at 1 millimeter scale.
Remember, I don't know
if you caught that.
But I showed 150--
101-- 150.
I showed you 168 IT neurons
predicted the pattern
of human performance.
I showed that a few slides ago.
But I told you the real number
of neurons is probably 50,000.
Most of those are
redundant copies
of that 168 dimensional
feature set.
That's how we think about it.
So you could imagine, it's
just a redundant set of about--
I like to think of about
100 features in IT which
are sampled maybe randomly
downstream neurons that are
then learned.
So when you learn faces
versus other things,
hey, there's lots of good
information about faces
versus other things.
And these face patches,
that's how they're defined.
But those neurons are
going to lean heavily--
this downstream neuron
is going to lean heavily
on those neurons.
And then these-- so that would
make these regions causally
involved.
So that doesn't mean you had
to pre-build in anything here.
You just learn this at
a downstream version.
And you would get
something that looks
like it would explain our data.
So we like that, because
it captures that case.
But it also captures
the more general case.
If you learn cars,
you're going to sample
from a different
subset of neurons.
But you're following
the same learning rule.
That's what I said earlier on.
So you end up--
we think this is
the initial state.
This is when you learn objects.
And so what we think is a
post learning, what you have
is again, about 100
to 150 IT sub regions,
each at 1 millimeter
scale, that are
supporting a number
of noun tasks
read off this common basis here.
That's the model
that we like, given
the kind of data that
I've been showing you.
The post learning
model, as we call it.
So the reason I'm
bringing this up
is probably for
the neuroscientists
to fix ideas about how we
think about IT as a basis set.
And this is--
I think Haim sort of
set this up nicely,
he sort of implied
similar things.
That somebody downstream
reads from it.
OK.
But now, we have
a more-- you know,
we're starting to have a more
concrete model, that we now,
I'm trying to start
to be physical
about it, about the size
of these regions connecting
to earlier data,
how many there are.
So we're gaining
inference on that
from these different
experiments.
And now, if you believe this,
it starts to make a prediction
of what's-- now we can
do causality, right?
Somebody mentioned that earlier.
And so, one of the things
we've been doing recently
is if we can start to silence--
look, the way I've drawn
this, this bit of tissue
for-- this is just
schematic-- is somehow
involved in this
task and that task.
Face task and car task.
But this bit of
tissue, only face task.
And that bit of
tissue, only car task.
And this bit of tissue, neither.
So if you believe that,
you had the tools,
you should be able
to go in and start
to silence little bits of IT.
And you should get
predictable patterns out
of the behavioral
deficits of the animal
when you make those
manipulations, right?
Everybody follow that?
Right?
OK.
And now the models
give you a framework
to build those
predictions and to also
estimate the magnitude of those
effects that you should see.
And so that's what we've
been doing more recently.
And I'll just give
you a taste of this,
because this is really ongoing.
But I think it connects
to what Gabriel
said earlier about now there
are these tools available to do
that.
Oh, I put that in from
an earlier talk where--
I think Google has a
thing called Inception.
And I don't know--
was it Google?
Or somebody has it-- you can't
do Inception unless you're
actually in a brain.
So are you going
to try to insert--
the reason we do this is my
student that is working on it
really wants to inject
signals in the brain.
There's a dream
about VMI, right?
Could you kind of
inject a percept?
And to do that,
you're going to need
to do experiments like this.
And you understand this
hardware to interact with it.
It's something we
talked about earlier.
So actually-- and Tonegawa's lab
has some cool Inception stuff
on memory.
But this is like inserting
an object/person.
So to do that, this has
been a dream for many of us
for a long time.
Can we reliably
disrupt performance
by suppressing 1
millimeter bits of IT?
So to do that,
what we're doing is
testing a large battery
of tasks and a battery
of suppression patterns.
So not just sort
of saying, can we
affect face tasks or one task?
But let's imagine we
test a battery of tasks.
And then, we--
and the idea where
we'd have a whole bunch of tasks
and we'd do every bit of IT one
by one, and then in
combination, and we'd
sort of get all that data
and figure out what's
going on, right?
That's sort of the dream, right?
So we're trying to build
towards that dream.
Do you guys get it?
Right.
I mean, I don't know.
And then we're motivated
by this kind of idea here.
So to build-- so we started--
I'm just going to give
you a quick tour of we
have tools to start to do this.
You know, this is
our recording, we
can localize what we're
recording two very fine grain
using x-rays.
So we know exactly where
we're recording the IT to like
about 300 micron resolution.
So that's why I'm
putting this slide up.
And what we're
interested in is going,
if I silence this bit of
IT, or that bit of IT,
or that bit of IT, so actually
do this experiment, what
happens behaviorally?
And Arash Afraz is a
post-doc in the lab, started
these actual experiments.
And one of the things
Arash did was to first say,
let's see if we can get this
silencing of optogenetics tool
to work in our hands.
And the reason we were
so excited about that
is because we think
lesions, if we
can make temporary
brief silencing,
that that will give it much more
reliable disruption of behavior
that then, if we started
to try to inject signals,
which would be our dream, but
that seems too risky to us.
We just want to say, what
is a temporary lesion
of each bit of IT do?
And optogenetics is
cool, because there's
no other technique that
can briefly silence--
temporarily silence activity.
You can do pharmacological
manipulations,
but those last for hours.
So this could briefly
silence bits of IT.
And that's why we
were excited about it.
We also did pharmacological
manipulation as a reference
to get started.
But what we're doing is trying
to silence 1 millimeter regions
of IT using light delivered
through optical fibers
as the recording electrode.
And to silence bits
of neurons here.
And so what Arash
did was first show
that you can actually
silence neurons in this way.
So if you guys haven't
seen optogenetics plots,
this is data from our lab.
What's quite cool
about this, again,
is you have the same
images are being presented.
So this green line
should be up here.
But Arash turns a laser on right
here, shines light on there.
And there's some opsins
expressed in the neurons
in that local area.
And you can see it just sort
of shuts the thing down, and it
sort of deletes or blocks this.
You have the same
input coming in.
But you can sort
of delete it here.
And this is another example.
These are some pretty
strong examples.
It's not always this strong.
But this is, again, you
can see we can return back
to normal right away, right?
So this is a 200
millisecond silencing.
You could go even
narrower than that.
But so this is what
we had done so far.
And again, what we
did was say, look.
This is a risky tool.
This is it not going
to work at all.
So Arash just wanted
to test something
that was likely to work.
And so we picked a
face task because there
was a lot of evidence of
spatial clustering of faces
that you'll hear from
Winrich and you also
known in the literature.
So what Arash did
was to say, we picked
a task of discriminating
males from females.
We put in our notion
of invariance.
It's not just do
this image access.
But you have to do it across
a bunch of transformations.
In this case, its identity
as a transformation.
So you're saying, all of these
are supposed to be called male,
and all these are called female.
And he wanted you to
distinguish this from this.
That's what he trained
a monkey to do.
And just to give you the upshot,
is that, we do all this work,
we silence the bits of cortex.
And here's the big take home.
You get a 2% deficit of
single one millimeter
silencing of bits of IT cortex.
Parts of IT cortex,
not all of IT cortex,
produce a 2% deficit.
Here's the animal running
at 80%, 6% correct.
These are interleaved
trials where we
silence some local bit of IT.
You get a 2% deficit.
That's true only in the
contralateral field,
not that ipsilateral
field, for the aficionados.
You might look at this 2%
and go, well, that's tiny.
But we looked at it,
this is exactly what's
predicted by the models
that we were talking about.
It's right in the range
of what should happen.
And so this, to us,
is really quite cool.
This is highly significant.
And now we sort of are in
position to start to say,
OK these tools work.
They do what
they're supposed to.
And now we can start to
expand that task space.
So this result has been
published recently,
if you're interested in this.
And here is one of the
ways we're going forward
is that Rish Rajaingham, the one
doing those tasks in the monkey
I showed you earlier.
Silencing different parts of IT.
This is now with muscimol,
different bits of IT--
these are different tasks,
lead to different patterns.
That's what these
dots are here--
different patterns of deficits.
And if you go back
to the same location,
you get the same
pattern of deficits.
So this is only 10 tasks.
But I think it
hopefully gives you
the spirit of what
we're trying to do.
And again, this
is only muscimol,
which doesn't have all the
advantages of optogenetics.
But this is what we're
were building towards here.
So I'm just giving you the
sort of state of the art.
So our aim is to measure
the specific pattern
of behavioral change induced by
the suppression of each IT sub
region, ideally
testing many of them,
and then compare with
the model predictions.
I'm saying there's
this domain, and I
want to sort of sample
the whole domain.
So far, I've given you only just
samples of tasks in the domain.
But we're really trying
to define the domain.
And I'm just--
I'm going to skip through this
just to give you the punchline,
is that we do a whole bunch
of behavioral measurements.
We presented this work before.
It's like, this is now up to
three million Mechanical Turk
trials.
It seems to us that we can
embed all objects, even
subordinate objects,
of the type of task
that I've been telling
you, in roughly,
in essentially a 20
dimensional space.
So there's 20 dimensions.
We think we infer that
humans are projecting
to about 20 dimensions to
do these kind of, the tasks
that we've shown here.
Which is sort of
smaller, but eerily
close to that in the
order of magnitude
to that 100 or so features
that I've been talking about.
So that's where-- regardless
of whether-- these
are some of the dimensions
and how we're projecting them.
Again, I won't take
you through this,
because I think we've
already used up enough time
and I want to get
on to this part.
But we're trying to define
a domain of all tasks
where we can sort
of predict what
would happen across
anything within that domain.
And that raises questions of the
dimensionality of that domain.
And there were behavioral
methods to do that.
And we've been doing
some work on that.
So I'll just leave it at that.
And if you guys
have questions, we
can talk about that some more.
I want to sort of
in the time I really
have left is to talk about
the encoding side of things,
because I promised you
guys I would get to this.
Unless people have
any more burning
questions on this decoding side.
So far I've been
talking about the link
between IT and perception.
Now I'm going to switch gears
and talk about this other side.
Which is, so I
talked about this.
And that tells us that
the mean rates in IT
are something that seem
to be highly predictive.
I showed you at
least one model that
has the laws of RAD IT model.
But now, it's like now, we
can turn to the encoding side
and say, we need to predict
the mean rates of IT.
And that should be our goal
if we want to explain images
to IT activity.
So, these would be called
predictive encoding mechanisms.
So, now you guys
have heard about
deep convolutional networks.
If not, you've heard
about them already,
you'll probably hear
about them some more.
So we started messing
around in 2008.
This is a model inspired--
I mentioned this family
of models before.
Hubel-Wiesel, Fukushima, and
there's a whole HMAX family
of models, that really was the
inspiration of this larger--
this large family
of models, that
have this repeating
structure that are now
really the sort of modern
day deep convolution networks
really grew out of all
of this earlier work.
And so we started exploring
the family in 2008.
And just, this is a slide that
you've already sort of seen
a version of this from
Gabriel where you know,
for when you take an
image, you pass it
through a set of operators.
So you have filters.
So these are dot products
over some restricted spatial
restricted region,
like receptive fields.
You have a non linear area, like
a threshold and a saturation.
You have pooling operation.
Then you have a normalization.
So you have all these
operations happen here.
And that produces a stack.
So think of like, if there
are four filters here,
like four orientations,
you get four images,
you have one image in,
you have four images out.
But if you had 10 of these,
you'd get 10 of these out.
Then you repeat
this here, right?
And so as you keep
adding more filters,
this stack just keeps
getting bigger and bigger.
And it keeps, because
you're spatially pooling,
it keeps getting narrower
and narrower, right?
So you go from this
image to this sort
of deep stack of features
that has less retinatopy.
It still has a little
bit of retinotopy.
And that, you can see, has
been exactly a very good model
why people liked
it of how people
think about the ventral stream.
So these models
typically have thousands
of feat-- visual neurons or
features at the top level.
Just to give you a sense of
scale of how they're run.
And just to take
you through, you
know, I guess maybe
you'll hear about this,
if you haven't already.
Each element has like, a
filter, has a large fan in.
Like these are like
neuroscience related things.
They have non-linearities,
like thresholds of neurons.
Each layer is
convolutional, which
means you apply the same
filters across visual space.
Which is like retinotopy,
that is a view on cell that
is oriented here.
There'll be another
view on cell that's
in another spatial
position, same orientation,
different spatial position.
That's what the
convolutional models are just
an implementation of that idea
of copying the same filter
type across the retina.
And there's a deep
stack of layers.
These are all
things that I think
are commensurate with
the ventral stream
anatomy and physiology.
So, but one of the
key things that those
who work with these
models know is
that, they have lots
of unknown parameters
that are not determined
from the neurobiology.
Even though the family of
models is well described,
what are the exact
filter weights?
What are the
threshold parameters?
How exactly do you pool?
How do you normalize?
There's lots of parameters
when you build these things,
essentially thousands of
parameters, most of them hidden
in the weight structure here.
Which, if you think about,
the first layer, that
would be like, should
I choose Gabor filters?
Or should I do some other--
you know Haim was talking
about random weights, right?
So there's choices there.
There are lots of parameters.
So the upshot is, there's
a big-- that's why
I call it a family of models.
And how do you choose which one
is the right one, so to speak?
Or is there a right one?
Or maybe the whole
family is wrong, right?
These are the
interesting discussions.
So, what I like about it is,
at least when you set it,
it's a model.
It makes predictions.
And then you can test it.
So it's at least a model.
And it predicts the
entire-- you know,
if you start to map these, you
say this is V1, this is V2,
this is V4.
It predicts the full
neural population response
to any image across these areas.
So it's a strongly
predictive model once built.
So that's nice.
But now you have to determine
how am I going to build it?
How do I set the parameters?
So how do we do that?
Well, there's lots of
ways you could do it.
And I'll tell you the
way we chose to do it.
Which was to just not
use any neural data.
It was just to use
optimization methods
to find specific models
to set the parameters
inside this model class.
And we chose an
optimization target.
This is a little bit, again,
inspired from a top down view
of what the system's doing.
What are the visual
tasks that we
suppose the ventral stream
was supposed to solve?
Which I already told you, we
think it's invariant object
recognition.
That's what makes
the problem hard.
So we tried to optimize
models to solve that.
And essentially when
we're doing that,
we're kind of doing the same
thing that computer vision is
trying to do, except we're doing
it in our own domain of images
and tasks that we set up.
But we essentially, there's a
meeting between computer vision
and what we were
trying to do here.
And when I say we, this
is work by Dan Yamins,
a post-doc in the lab, and
Ha Hong, a graduate student.
And what we did was to
just try to simulate again,
as I did earlier.
We took these
simple 3-D objects.
We could render
them, just as before,
place them on
naturalistic background.
And then we just
built models that
would try to discriminate
bodies from buildings
from flowers from guns.
So they would have
good feature sets
that would discriminate
between these things.
And these were essentially
trained by various forms
of supervision.
Now there's lots of ways
you can train these models.
I could tell you
about how we did it
and how others have done it.
I think those details
are beyond what
I want to talk about today.
But just, it's a
supervised class
that's probably not
learned in the same way
that the brain has learned.
Most people don't think so.
But the interesting
thing is the end state
of these models might look very
much like the current adult
state of the brain.
And that's what I want
to try to tell you next.
So first, let me show you that
when we built these models,
this was in 2012.
We had a particular
optimization approach
that we called HMO
that was trying
to solve these kind of problems
that I showed you earlier
on these kind of images.
And I showed you IT was
pretty good with humans.
I showed you its performance
was almost up to humans, even
with just 168 samples.
And when we first
built a model here,
we were able to do
much better than some
of our previous models that--
on these same kind of tasks.
So I told you we
constructed, because we
knew it made these things--
we made these models
not do so well.
So we built these
high invariance tasks
to push these models down.
And then we had space
to build a model
that we could do better on.
And we called it HMO 1.0.
And then we started
to say, now we
have this model that has been
optimized for performance.
Let's see how well it does
on comparing with neurons.
Let's see if its internals
look like the neural data.
So here's the model
we built, HMO 1.0.
It's a deep
convolutional network.
It has two different levels.
It had four levels.
It had a bunch of parameters
that we set by optimization,
that I'm just telling you
kind of what we optimized.
I didn't tell you--
I'm not telling you
any of the parameters.
And now, we come back
to say, well look.
We can show the same
images to the model
that we showed to the neurons.
And then we can compare how
well these populations look
like that population, or this
population looks like that.
And so what we did was, we asked
how well can layer four predict
IT first?
That was the first
thing we wanted
to do, take the top
layer of this model,
the last layer before the
linear readout of this model.
And to do that, you might sort
of say, well, wait a minute.
The model doesn't have mappings.
It has sort of neurons simulated
here, neuron 12 or something.
And there's some
neuron we recorded.
But there's no linkage between
that neuron and that neuron,
right?
You have to make that map.
So what we do is we
take each IT neuron
and treat this as sort
of a generative space.
You can generate as many
simulated IT neurons
as you want.
You would just ask,
let's take this neuron,
take some of its data, and try
to build a linear regression
to this neuron.
Treat this as a basis
to explain that neuron.
And then test the predictive
power on the held out IT data.
And that's what
I'm writing here.
That's cross-validation
linear regression.
So I'm going to show you
predictions on held out data
where some of the data were
used to make the mapping.
And there's lots
of ways we chose--
we could make the mapping.
And we did essentially
all of them.
And I could talk about
that if you want.
But that's this central idea.
Take some of your data, say,
is this in the linear space
spanned by this basis set?
So I can I fit that well
with this linear basis here?
As a linear map from this basis?
And here's what we actually--
here's what it looks like.
Here's the IT neural response
of one simulated-- one actual IT
neuron in black.
This is not time.
These are images.
I think there's like
1,600 images here.
So each black going up and
down, you can barely see,
is the response, the mean
response, to different images.
And you see we grouped them
by categories, just so,
just to help you kind
of understand the data.
Otherwise, it'd
just be a big mess.
Because IT neurons
do-- you can kind of
see they have a bit of
category selectivity.
And again, this was known.
This neuron seems to like
chair images, but not all chair
images.
It sometimes likes boats and
some planes a little bit.
And the red line is the
prediction of the model,
once fit to part of
the-- to this neuron.
This is the prediction on the
held out data for the neuron.
You can see the R
squared is 0.48.
So half the explainable
response variance
is explained by this model.
And again, these
are predictions.
The images were never seen--
the objects even were
never seen by this model
before it makes these
predictions here.
So this is just saying that the
IT neurons live in this space.
It's actually quite well
captured by the top level,
in this case, of this
first HMO model we built.
I'll show you some other
models in a minute.
Here's another neuron
that you might call a face
neuron because it tends to like
faces over other categories.
So it might-- it
would pass the test
of the operational
definition of a face neuron.
This model, this neuron
was well predicted, again,
by both its preferred and
non-preferred face images
by this HMO model.
Again, a slightly--
an R squared near 0.5.
Here's a neuron that you would
look at the category structure.
And you don't even--
you can't really see
the categories here.
They're still here.
But you don't see
these sort of blocks.
You just see there's sort of
some images it likes and some
it doesn't.
It's hard to even know
what's driving this neuron.
But it's actually quite
well predicted, I think.
You don't have the R squared.
But it's similar.
It's about half the
explainable variance.
Just another example.
And here is a sort
of summary here.
If you take-- this
is a distribution
of the explainable variance
for the top level of the model
fitting about, I think
this is 168 IT sites.
Some sites are fit
really well, near 100%.
Some are fit not as well.
The average is about
50%, which is shown here.
So this is the median of
that distribution here.
So the summary take
home is about 50%
of singularly response
variance predicted.
And this is a big improvement
over previous models
I'll show you in a minute.
The other levels of the model
don't predict nearly well.
So the first level
doesn't predict well.
Second level better,
third level better,
the fourth level the best.
If you take other models-- these
are some of the models I showed
you earlier--
they don't fit nearly as well.
Here's their distributions
and here's their average,
their median explained variance.
And just to fix-- to just
fix ideas, you might think,
well look, we built a model
that's a good categorizer.
So of course it fits
IT neurons well.
Because IT neurons
are categorizers.
Well, here's a model that
actually has explicit knowledge
of the category.
It's not an image
computable model,
and it's not an easy one.
But it's just given
that sort of an oracle
that's given the category,
and how well it explains IT.
And you can see, it
explains IT much worse
than the actual model.
So this implies a model
is limited by the real--
the architecture puts
constraints on the model
and how it adds variance
that the sustained IT
neurons are categories
does not easily capture.
So that kind of--
that sort of inspired
us to say, OK.
What about if we go down
and say not just IT,
but let's go to V4.
Because we had a
bunch of V4 data.
And so we play the
same game in V4.
Let's take level three and
see if we can predict V4.
And here's the IT data I
just showed you a minute ago.
And here's the V4 data.
So the V4 neurons are highly
predicted in the middle layer.
Layer three is the
best predictor of V4.
The top layer is actually not
so predictive, less predictive
of V4 neurons than
the middle layers.
And the first layer is
not so well predictive.
And again, the other
models are actually,
now you can see they're
getting on relatively better.
You can think of them as
sort of lower level models.
And they're getting better,
which is what you'd expect.
But interestingly, this
is really exciting to us.
Because look, this
model was not optimized
to fit any neural data other
than that last mapping step.
All it is is a bio
inspired algorithm class,
which is the
neuroscience sort of view
of the feed-forward
class of the field.
And tasks that we and
others hypothesize
are important, that
the ventral stream
might be optimized to solve,
and an actual optimization
procedure that we applied.
And that leads to neural like
encoding functions at the top
and in the middle layer.
So you don't-- so this sort
of leads to funny things like
saying, what does V4 do?
The answer here
would be, well, it's
an intermediate layer
in a network built
to optimize these things.
That's the way to
describe what V4
does, according to this
kind of modeling approach.
Now I want to point
out, this is only half
of the explainable variance.
So it's far from perfect.
There's room to improve here.
But it's really dramatic how
much improvement we got out
of these kind of models.
And so if you take
this sort of--
well, I'll skip this.
If you take this back to
you know, big picture,
what did we do here?
What we're doing is
we have performance
of a model on high end
variance recognition tasks.
We're saying, this is what
we've been trying to optimize.
And what we noticed
is that if you
plot-- these dots are samples
out of that model family.
These black dots are
other models I showed you.
So they're control models that
were in the field at the time.
And this is the
ability of the top--
the model-- the top level
of any of the models
to predict IT responses.
So, you know, how good
they are predicting--
this is sort of the median
variance explained of single IT
responses.
And you see there's
a correlation here.
If you're better at this, you're
better at predicting that.
And all we did was
optimize this way,
which we think of as like,
evolution or development.
So we're not
fitting neural data.
We're just optimizing
for task performance.
And that led in 2012 to a
model that I just showed you,
explained about half of
the IT response variance.
OK, so it's like, well,
this looks like it's
continuing up this way.
OK so if you believe that
story, then, that says,
if we can optimize further
on these kind of tasks,
maybe we can explain
more variance.
And it turned out,
we didn't actually
need to do that,
because again, I said,
computer vision was
already working on this.
And they got a lot
more resources.
They're already doing it.
They're already better
than us on this.
So here's our HMO model.
This is now Charles Cadieu,
a post-doc in the lab.
These were models that
came out at the time.
This is Krizhevski
et al. supervision.
It's ICLR 2013.
They were better than the
model that we had built.
You know, we were in this
restricted image domain,
you know, there's
lots of reasons why
we could say they're better.
Regardless, they were better at
our own tasks than the models
that we had built, right?
So they were already
ahead of us on the task
that we had designed.
And so they were up here,
and then they were up here.
And so, if you follow
that prediction,
that means these models
might be better predictors
of our neural data, right?
These guys don't
have our neural data.
All they're doing is building
models to optimize performance
on tasks.
And but we could take their
features from the neural data,
play the same game.
And we actually explained
our response-- data
better than our model
explained our own data.
So this is a nice statement
that is not even in our own lab.
Just a continued optimization
for those kinds of tasks
leads to features that are good
predictors of the IT responses.
And that's what's shown here.
So I think that's what
I just said there.
So, Charles took this
further and analyzed
this in more detail.
This is a summary of what I
presented in the second half
now, showing that IT firing
rates are feature based,
learned object judgments
naturally predict human monkey
performance.
This is why the laws of RAD IT.
I picked a particular
model, which
is 100 millisecond read on this
time window, 50,000 neurons.
100 training examples.
That's one particular choice of
a decode model, that's just a--
is a current set of decode model
that fits a lot of our data,
but not all of our data.
And we also want to
get finer grain data.
The inference is, this might
be the specific neural code
and decoding mechanism
that the brain uses
to support these tasks.
That's what we'd like to think.
But now, we're trying to
do systematic causal tests.
And we talked a lot about
trying to silence bits of IT
as one example of that.
And the tools are still not
where we'd like them to be.
But you see we're
making progress there.
So the second was I showed the
optimization of deep CNN models
for invariant object
recognition tasks led
to dramatic improvements
in our ability
to predict IT and V4 responses.
I showed you our model HMO.
But then the convolutional
neural networks in the field
have already surpassed
our predictive ability
on our own data.
And so the inference is that
these encoding mechanisms
in these models might
be similar to those that
work in the ventral stream.
And now, you know, there's
a whole sort of area
where you can start to
think about doing physiology
on the models, so to speak.
And that problem's
almost as hard
as doing physiology
except on the animal,
except that you can
gain a lot more data.
And so, and this is
allowing the field
to design experiments
to explore what remains,
what's unique and powerful
about primate object perception.
So within core
object recognition
or perhaps having to
extend out of that,
I think is now what
people are trying to do.
So big picture in terms
of us for the future,
I've talked about
this law's of RAD IT.
Can we perturb here
and get effects here
that are predictable?
Can we predict for each
image, coding model,
and for the optical
manipulations?
We talked about that.
Dynamics and feedback
are something
that we're interested in.
But I haven't talked
much at all about.
I think that's a good
point, a discussion topic.
I can tell you how
we're thinking about it.
We have some efforts
in that regard.
I talked on the encoding
side about these kind
of deep convolutional
networks that map from images.
But the dash lines mean
they're only 50% predicted.
Both of these cases,
they're not perfect, right?
So there's work
to be done there.
And one of the really
exciting things
is here is how
these models learn.
This supervised way of
learning these models
is almost surely not what's
going on in the brain.
So finding more-- less
supervised, biologically
motivated learning
of these models
is a good-- is the next step,
I think, for much of the field.
But what's nice is to
have an end state that
is much better than any previous
end state we'd had before.
So that sets a target of
what success might look like.
And you know, maybe we
can think about expanding
beyond core recognition.
We can talk in the
question period about that.
When is the right
time to kind of keep
working within the domain
of core recognition that
is set up, versus
expanding beyond that?
Because there's lots
of aspects of object
recognition that I
didn't touch on here.
And that comes up
in the questions.
I think, there's lots of work
to be done within the domain,
but there's also
interesting directions that
extend outside of that domain.